[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be discussing 10 myths about the
series itself since the release of the
first Harry Potter novel in June of
1997 The Wizarding World of Harry and
his friends has continued to expand what
started off as a relatively small
magical community that only focused on
the United Kingdom grew into a global
universe and Phenomenon with new and
exciting narratives being brought to
life in Europe the Americas Asia and
Africa what was once known as Pottermore
a site where fans could go to learn more
about the Magical World of Harry Potter
became the Wizarding World and grew to
include new franchises like Fantastic
Beasts and short stories about things
like the founding of North American
witing School ilver morning School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry so while at one
point in time of over 25 years ago it
may have been somewhat easy to keep the
magical constructs that made up The
Wizarding World of Harry Potter straight
it has since become increasingly
difficult to truly know everything about
this magical universe as a result
sometimes even the most devoted fans get
details about Harry Potter well wrong
and with fan certainty that they are
correct answering queries on Reddit and
other web forms it's not surprising that
some of these myths about the series
have gained lives of their own and have
been circulated around the internet as
fact which is why in today's video I'll
be taking you through 10 of the most
pervasive myths out there some of which
may even surprise you myth one hogwart's
acceptance letters arrive on a child's
11th birthday for some strange reason
many fans around the world believe that
if a boy or girl has magical abilities
They will receive their letter of
acceptance to a Whiting School on their
11th birthday this is in actual fact
wrong and if you're questioning me here
think about it while Harry did
eventually open his letter of acceptance
to Hogwart School of whichcraft and
Wizardry on his 11th birthday that
timing was just a happy accident for as
you may recall the very first version of
his letter of acceptance actually
arrived at number four privet Drive
weeks before that and between the
delivery of Harry's first letter by post
and Ruby's Hagrid finally hand
delivering it to him on his birthday
there were many other attempts to
deliver the duplicates of this same
letter number four Private Drive was
even bombarded by heaps of letters that
magically flooded into the dersley home
several days before Harry turned 11 so
when do children actually receive their
acceptance letter to hog Walts well as
you may have guessed from the timing of
Harry's first letter young witches and
wizards typically received their
acceptance letters in August a couple of
weeks before the start of the school
year myth 2 Hogwarts is located in
England while I know this belief to be a
myth I do understand why so many people
believe it to be true Harry is English
his best friends are English most of his
professors are English heck even the
majority of the characters who meet at
Hogwart School are indeed English
combine that with the fact that Hogwarts
is unplottable with no known location at
least to us Muggles and it's easy to
draw the conclusion that the school's
Castle is located in England and yet it
is not hogwart's Castle is Al hidden
somewhere among the Scottish Highlands
with Whiting world.com even confirming
the following hogars was built somewhere
in the Scottish Highlands and concealed
with numerous charms and spells to make
it impossible for Muggles to trespass
there's also the fact that the Hogwarts
Express travels through the Scottish
Highlands trust me I've seen it myth
three the house animal of Ravenclaw is a
raven when it comes to the animals of
the four houses at Hogwarts they all
seem pretty obvious and straightforward
gryffindor's animal is a lion sutherin
is a serpent huffle Puffs is a badger
and ravenclaws is a raven right well no
actually not right while the first three
houses in their Associated animals are
correct the true house animal of
Ravenclaw is actually an eagle chosen
for the predatory Bird's Raven colored
claws unfortunately for purest of the
Harry Potter novels this myth was given
some real legs when the films decided to
change ravenclaw's animal from an eagle
to a raven since that's the bird that
most people think of when they hear
Ravenclaw myth four poly juice potion
only changes a person's appearance if
you're primarily a fan of the Harry
Potter movies the inconsistency of the
effects of poly juu potion likely have
left you feeling a little confused on
the topic while in the novels poly juu
consistently affects the Drinker of the
potion the same way it actually varies
quite a bit through the movie franchise
in the books someone who drinks poly
juice potion takes on the intended
person's appearance physical
capabilities as well as their voice what
I mean by physical capabilities is for
example their eyesight or strength but
in the movies these things change
depending on which film you're watching
take the poly juice potion scene in the
film adaptation of the Chamber of
Secrets Harry transforms into but
unlike in the book Harry's vision and
voice remain the same Ron also keeps his
own voice after transforming into crab
during that same scene in the movies and
yet later in the series in the gulit of
fire Barty crunch Jr impersonates
Professor mad Moody for the majority of
the film using poly juu potion the
notable difference between the effects
of poly juu potion here is that Barty
crunch Jr takes on Mad I's voice and his
lack of an eye then in the Deathly
Hallows movies we see the Order of the
Phoenix all become Harry and each keep
their own voices but not their own
Vision Harry Ron and herione also keep
their own voices when they break into
the ministry of magic as Ministry
employees with all of these
inconsistencies it would be rather
surprising if people weren't confused
about the true effects of polyu potion
but again to clarify it changes
everything about you including your
voice and vision myth five herione is
the smartest of the trio brainy herione
Granger has quite the reputation for
being an incredibly intelligent witch
noted to have been one of the top
students in her year at quarts with her
head very often stuck in a book there's
no doubt that herione is a smart person
and yet I wouldn't necessarily classify
her as the smartest out of herself Harry
and Ron or the trio if you will of
course she's definitely the most well
read but both Harry and Ron bring an
intelligence of their own to the trio on
more than one occasion we see the boys
rise to the challenge and figure a way
out of dangerous situations while hmane
stands stunned somewhere nearby take for
instance the the fact that it was
actually Ron who figured out how to
escape from the devil's snare in the
philosopher stone as herione panicked
beside him myth 6 Ron is actually quite
stupid while we unpacked this a little
in the previous myth the idea that Ron
Wiley is actually a big dumb Dum is one
myth that really bumps me out that said
for fans who are mostly invested in the
movies I get it the films really do
portray Ron as a bit of a buffoon but in
the novels he's actually quite a smart
wizard he knows loads about Wizarding
culture and is often a resource to Harry
and amione on this topic even teaching
Harry how to play Wizard's chess a
rather intellectual board game Ron also
consistently receives similar grades to
Harry at school which essentially means
that he's just as books smart as the
famous and talented boy who lived and
did I mention that he got the trio out
of that Devil's snare in the philosopher
stone myth 7 Hogwarts is the only co-ed
School in the triz a tournament alas yet
another myth perpetuated by the films is
that the northern European durmstrang
Institute and French baton Academy of
magic are single-ended schools that is
many fans incorrectly assume that
durmstrang is an all Wizarding school
and Baton only accepts witches this
couldn't be further from the truth as
both educational institutions admit both
witches and wizards the reason for this
incorrect assumption seems to be a
direct result of the fact that in the
Goblet of Fire film DM Strang arrives at
quarts with a gaggle of wizards while
Bor dances in with a fleet of witches in
the novel however the attendees from
each School are two much smaller co-ed
groups of hand selected witches and
wizards myth 8 bad Wizards cannot cast
patronises in the prison of aaban we're
introduced to the petronis charm a spell
that is performed by mastering all of
your most positive memories and feelings
although incredibly difficult to cast
once performed correctly the Patronus
charm results in a positive energy force
that resembles an animal that is unique
to each and every witch or wizard these
silvery projections are called
patronises and they are the only known
defense against the likes of Dementors
and
leopolds and while it's true that in
order to properly and effectively cast a
petronis charm for which your wizard
needs to conjure positive emotions it
does not mean that the Caster needs to
be inherently good this myth is also
likely the result of it being a form of
defense against dark force
like Dementors however that does not
exclude the charm from being a spell
that dark witches and wizards can use
after all just because a person is evil
doesn't mean they don't have happy
memories that they can leverage to cast
a Patronus just take Dolores Umbridge
for example she's an insane person who
tortures students and sympathizes with
Death Eaters yet she very clearly casts
a strong Patronis charm in the form of a
Persian cat why because she has many
good memories of her fulfilling her Duty
even if her duty is contemplating using
the cruciatus curse on a student myth
nine drao is not a bully but a victim
once again we have a rather clear
division of opinion between those who
prefer the Harry Potter novels to those
who prefer the films in this case the
differing opinions are in regard to the
infamous Southern student Draco Malfoy
while it's likely that no one would
object to the fact that Maloy started
off his time at Hogwarts as a big meanie
there are many the major majority of
which are fans of the movies who claim
that he actually became a victim near
the end of the series leaving behind his
once Petty ways of bullying others now I
suppose the argument around this
particular sentiment would be that he's
given an impossible task by Voldemort
presumably targeted for his father's
inadequacies as a death heater the task
he's given is to kill Professor Alber
Dumbledore a task that many believe to
be a suicide mission now as Dumbledore
was one of the most feared wizards of
his time having been the only one strong
enough to defeat the dark wizard G
grinder Wald it is almost laughable to
think of Draco Malfoy attempting to
assassinate him and yet I really don't
think that's enough to view him as the
victim after all Draco was fully
planning to go through with trying to
murder Dumbledore remember his elaborate
plan with the vanishing cabinets and
while we can't know for sure what would
have happened if sever Snape hadn't
stepped in and taken out alus instead at
Dumbledore's request mind you it seems
quite plausible that Draco would have at
least tried to kill him why because he's
a narcissist who will do anything to
survive of course if you ask a fan of
the films they'd likely disagree and
point to the movie adaptations
Redemption Arc that was given to Draco
which made little sense at least in my
opinion myth 10 the resurrection Stone
brought Harry back to life the 10th and
final myth that will be covering today
is the idea that Harry didn't die after
being hit for the second time by one of
Voldemort's killing curses because he
possessed the resurrection Stone now
there's a fair bit to unpack here first
of all when Harry was struck down by the
dark Lords of arav in the Forbidden
Forest he no longer had the resurrection
Stone in his possession he had used it
to see his deceased loved ones in order
to find the courage to face Voldemort
and sacrifice himself once he had
communicated with his dead family and
friends he tossed the stone aside and it
dropped to the forest floor never to be
seen again secondly the resurrect ction
Stone one of the three Deathly Hallows
is unable to fully bring a person back
to life from the dead as the legend goes
when the resurrection stone is used to
bring someone back from Death they
return only as a shadow of their former
selves separated from the living by a
sort of veil therefore even if Harry had
possessed the stone when he was hit by
the killing curse it would have been
impossible for it to bring him fully
back to life and Harry was pretty
clearly fully alive when he woke up in
the Forbidden Forest after returning
from from what some have called Limbo
finally the real reason Harry was able
to come back to life was due to the bit
of Voldemort's soul that had been
residing in his body since he was an
infant when he was struck by the dark
H's curse the spell killed the partial
Soul living inside Harry and left the
rest of him untouched at that point he
was able to make a choice whether or not
to return to the land of the living or
move on into death he of course chose to
come back and with that we've come to
the end of another video what did do you
think what are some myths about Harry
Potter that drive you crazy please share
your thoughts in the comments below and
as always if you enjoyed this video
don't forget to like it and subscribe to
the channel also be sure to check out
the content on Spotify as well as extra
content on my second Channel Harry
Potter Theory extra until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to
[Music]
live